Ralph Northam faces down his political
mortality President Trump heads to CBS
and we recap the Super Bowl today on the
Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
all righty we do have a lot to get to
today Ralph Northam the Virginia
governor still in trouble he's had
himself a very bad couple of weeks
what's weird in the Democratic Party is
saying that you want to kill like
fully-formed
infants just before they exit the birth
canal totally cool
35 year old racist rate Facebook four or
yearbook photo very bad resign go away
hang yourself that's that's our politics
right now we'll get to all of that in
just one second first let's talk about
what you're going to get your loved one
for Valentine's Day most of us have
started racking our brains about what
Valentine's Day gift is truly gonna make
her Day special well don't get the
flowers from the local grocery store
they are going to wilt in one second
flat instead go to 1-800 flowers calm
roses from 1-800 flowers are a
no-brainer and right now when you order
early you get the 18 stem enchanted Rose
medley for $29.99 or doublet to the
thirty-six stem enchanted roses for $20
more it's a great offer from 1-800
flowers again that's an 18 stem
enchanted rose medley for $29.99 or
double the roses for 20 bucks more than
I've been using 1-800 flowers for years
literally every time I go out of town on
one of my college trips I will send my
wife a bouquet of flowers let her know
that I am thinking of her I'm just that
kind of guy and you can be that kind of
human too if you use 1-800 flowers
they're picked at their peak and shipped
overnight to ensure freshness and her
amazement the 18 stem enchanted Rose
medley for $29.99 or double to 36 roses
for $20 more it's an amazing offer that
does expire on Wednesday so you're gonna
want to make sure you go take advantage
of it right now pick your delivery date
let 1-800 flowers handle the rest its
1-800 flowers come Shapiro's for the
special deal order today and save it
1-800 flowers , slash Shapiro from the
18 stem enchanted Rose medley for $29.99
or double the roses for 28 bucks more
1-800 flowers calm slash Shapiro okay
well everybody was watching an awful
boring terrible Super Bowl yesterday the
only saving grace of which was that the
greatest quarterback of all time Tom
Brady won his sixth Super Bowl well
everybody was watching that Ralph
Northam was having an emergency meeting
with a bunch of black members of his
administration and I guess that he's
gonna try and live this one out
so to recap you may remember governor
Ralph Northam from such things as kill
that fully formed baby in the middle of
dilation why sure right that was it that
was one of his starring efforts last
week you also may remember
from such wonderful things as here's a
photo of me 35 years ago either in
blackface or a KKK outfit now you know
your governorship is in trouble and the
question is which one are you the one in
blackface or the one in the KKK that
that's when you start thinking well I've
got a bit of a problem here now in a
second I want to talk about why our
standards in politics are just
ridiculous and we really should consider
whether or not we are willing to finish
people's careers for bad taste mistakes
that today look horribly racist
homophobic bigoted from like three
decades ago whether that is the standard
of destroying somebody's career which
means that legitimately we should only
elect new borns because those are people
who have not sinned in the past at least
to this point I mean at least if we're
not gonna kill them according to some
Democrats we'll get to that in a second
but first let's let's bring you up to
date on what is going on with Ralph
Northam who is fighting for his
political life and doing so with a
scalpel and also a blunderbuss so the
weekend started with him holding a press
conference where he said he apologized
for his past actions he apologized for
the racist video then things got real
weird so we start with him and his
apology earlier today I released a
statement apologizing for behavior in my
past that falls far short of the
standard you set for me when you elected
me to be your governor I believe you
deserve to hear directly from me that
photo and the racist and offensive
attitudes it represents does not reflect
that person I am today or the way that I
have conducted myself as a soldier a
doctor and a public servant I'm deeply
sorry okay now if that had been the
extent of his statement if he had said
listen 35 years ago people did really
stupid stuff then now we look on and we
are horrified by and I look back at that
and I'm horrified by it too and it never
should have happened and I honestly
forgotten about it because it's 35 years
ago but now that somebody's brought it
to my attention really a terrible thing
to have done I'm really sorry about that
and I hope that you'll look at my
totality of my record and see that this
is not who I am right that that would I
think be inappropriate apology and
frankly I think that it at that point
people should probably let it go
honestly but that's not what happened
then Ralph Northam decided you know what
for a second press conference now second
press conferences are not like second
breakfast from The Hobbit they from from
JRR tolkien second press conferences are
much much worse than then the first
press conference is almost always it's
hard to think of a situation where a
second press conference is actually
solidified things and made it better so
here it was R alpha more than doing a
press conference and he decided that
while he had apologized for his past
actions in that statement you heard one
second ago now he was going to not
apologize for that he was going to
apologize for a different time he
dressed as a black person apparently he
said it's not me in that photo from my
yearbook page standing there dressed as
a black person or as a KKK member my
favorite statement from the weekend is
that it was reported that northern
wanted to hire facial recognition
experts to show that it wasn't his face
in that photo how do you get a facial
recognition expert to show that it's not
you underneath a KKK hood can the facial
recognition experts so it's going on
under like I thought the purpose of
having the white sheet over your head if
you're a KKK member is so the people who
can't recognize your face in any case
Ralph Northam said he wanted to do that
apparently and then it got even better
so he said that wasn't me that picture
was not me the one from my yearbook page
you know right above my name which
legitimately is what I mean was in his
yearbook page from medical school then
he said no that wasn't me but there was
another party that I went to where I
dressed up as Michael Jackson now first
things first let me suggest that if you
dress up as random person in blackface
to make fun of black people I don't
think it's the same thing as you
dressing up as Michael Jackson in 1985
and putting on black makeup to do so I
just don't think it's the exact same
thing I think it's still not great but
I'm not gonna pretend that I think that
it's mocking in the same way that
dressing up as random black person in
1910 is right context it does matter in
a lot of this stuff with that said again
you know you're in trouble when you have
to distinguish for the press we're
either guy in blackface or the guy in
the KKK hood and then you have to
distinguish from that or was I the guy
who took shoe polish as he's about to
explain shoe polish and make up your
face to look like Michael Jackson circa
1985 so here he was explaining wasn't me
in that yearbook photo but if there's
another photo of me dressed up as
Michael Jackson looking
like I dressed like a black guy maybe
that's me in the hour since I made my
statement yesterday I reflect it with my
family and classmates from the time and
affirm to my conclusion that I am NOT
the person in that photo that same year
I did participate in a dance contest in
San Antonio in which I darken my face is
part of a Michael Jackson costume I look
back now and regret that I did not
understand the harmful legacy of an
action like that ok but then it got even
more ridiculous
so a reporter asked him you know mr.
governor
can you still moonwalk he said that he
was in a dance contest and nor them
who's obviously one of the most
intelligent people on the block and
we're honestly one of the most
disappointing things about becoming an
adult is realizing all the adults are
stupid Adam Carolla makes this point all
the time
then when you're a kid you look at all
the adults and you say that person has a
nice house that person has a nice car
that person has clothes and a TV and
they can step to whatever time they want
they can eat whatever they want they
must be super smart and then as you grow
up you realize that all the kids who are
sitting next to you in class eating
their boogers are the adults with whom
you are also an adult well it's the same
thing when you look at folks like Ralph
Northam yeah honestly like this guy is
the governor of Virginia and he's just
an idiot he's just an idiot and I know
people well he's a doctor that means he
can't be stupid why is it that everybody
who says doctors can't be stupid also
thinks their own doctor is an idiot and
won't pay any attention to what they say
anyway Ralph Northam is asked to
moonwalk and it's spectacular he looks
around for space to moonwalk he does he
looks around the stage for it like do I
have space to it to moonwalk here and
then his wife gives him a look like
Ralph are you insane are you insane like
you're in the middle of a scandal about
dressing in blackface and you're about
to move let's watch it because it's
really great it's good stuff
yes that's right
[Music]
my wife says and appropriate
circumstances my favorite part of that
clip is the big grin and he's like I'm
gonna do this thing I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna moonwalk and then he gets all
disappointed cuz his wife is like no no
just know what Ralph what are you doing
don't moonwalk so maybe this this does
lend some credibility to the idea that
the guy isn't a racist you just an idiot
it doesn't that lend something
credibility to the idea that he's just a
maybe I mean my goodness and then it
turns out that back in the day people
called him a slur that was used for
black people I don't know 50 years ago
must have been common maybe I don't know
I don't know that much about this
particular racial slur but apparently
his nickname was the racist slur
man which is just lovely
so someone he's asked about that it's
like I have no idea why people called me
that maybe it's cuz I like to go raccoon
hunting or something like okay all right
go round or them my main nickname in
high school and in college was goose
because when my voice was changed and I
would change an octave there were two
individuals that's best I can relax at
VMI they were a year ahead of me they
called me man I don't know their
motives or intent I know who they are
but that was the extent of that and it
ended up in the yearbook and I regret
that yeah so okay fine all right fine
well let's just point out a couple of
things okay number one the weaponization
of racism means that he doesn't get off
here right well we're going to talk in a
second about what our general standards
for politicians should be but the the
way that racism now works is that it has
been completely weaponized meaning that
if somebody does something any time in
the past or the present thing can be
even construed as racist they will be
ruined politically and Ralph Northam was
a full-scale participant in this sort of
nastiness he would take comments that
were not actually racist and then he
would construe them as racist in order
to slander his political opposition in
the most vile
ashin I will show you that in just one
second first let's talk about how you
can make your business more efficient
this year well you can hire better
people but hiring can be really
time-consuming you post a job dat
several online job boards only to get
tons of the wrong resumes then you have
to sort through all of those resumes
just to find a few people with the right
skills and experience job sites that
overwhelm you at the wrong resumes those
are not smart that's why you should do
the smart thing and go to zip recruiter
comm slash daily wire
unlike other job sites zip recruiter
finds qualified candidates just for you
it's powerful matching technology
actively scans thousands of resumes to
identify people with the right skills
education and experience and then
invites them to apply to your job so you
get qualified candidates fast it's no
wonder that zip recruiter is rated
number one by employers in the United
States this rating comes from hiring
sites on trust pilot with over 1000
reviews and right now my listeners can
try zip recruiter for free an exclusive
web address zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire if you love the show show
your support for it and zip recruiter by
going to zip recruit comm slash daily
Wire Dai ly w ir e at zip recruiter comm
slash daily wire zip recruiter is indeed
the smartest way to hire why are you
wasting time on all of these silly job
sites that are never gonna find you what
you need instead go to zip recruiter
comm slash daily wire we use it here at
the day of the wire for precisely the
reasons I just suggested to you and you
can try it for free right now zip
recruiter comm slash daily wear ok so as
I say Ralph Northam has been an active
participants in the weaponization of the
charge of racism against people if you
recall all the way back to the 2016
election he ran an ad against his
opponent ed gillespie that is one of the
most vile ads I have legitimately ever
seen in a campaign it was an ad that
showed minority children running away
from a guy a white racist in a truck
with a Gillespie sticker on the back as
though ed gillespie was trying to run
down small black children in his truck
and Gillespie supporters were the people
at Charlottesville he was really
disgusting here is what that ad sounded
like
they're these kids were running away
there's a you can see a Confederate flag
on the back of a truck this is a super
PAC that ran it on behalf of nor them
northern ever denounced it here all
these minority kids and they're just
kind of running away running away from
this truck with a confederate flag on
the back and on the back of it there's a
Gillespie sticker and now all these kids
are running down the street there's
Muslim kid running all these kids and
running down the street again here comes
the truck trying to run down these
children trying to murder these children
they have a Gillespie sticker on the
back of the truck and the don't tread on
me license plate on the front now
remember this is a super PAC it was
associated with northern randon on his
behalf and then parents wake up to
comfort their children and remind them
not to vote for Ed Gillespie paid for by
Latino Victory Fund they say was not
authorized by any candidate but you
never saw northern come out and condemn
the ad so northern was an expert at this
he suggested that Ed Gillespie was a
racist for having mentioned ms-13 the
gang that was active in Virginia in
discussions about illegal immigration so
Gillespie participated full-scale in
this sort of stuff that means that if
you make any boo-boo at any time the
knives are gonna come out for you and
come out they did President Trump
grabbed a pitchfork and just rammed it
directly into Ralph Northam in the
middle of this in the middle of the
scandal President Trump tweeted out
Democrat governor draft none of them of
Virginia just stated I believe that I am
NOT either of the paper in that photo
this was 24 hours after apologizing for
appearing in the picture and after
making the most horrible statement on
super late term abortion unforgivable
now everybody on the left hand well you
know you make comments about
Charlottesville and others that's why
Trump is doing this because what he is
saying is you guys all call me racist
for stuff well it when the shoes on the
other foot I'm not gonna hold back I'm
not gonna pretend that that Ralph
Northam gets off easy now here's
something amazing there was a Florida
Secretary of State who had been
appointed by Governor Ron de Santos in
Florida to fill that position and there
was an old photo of him in blackface
from a party in like in the 1980s and he
resigned within a day this scandal broke
on Friday it is now Monday Ralph Northam
is still in office not only is he still
in office he's now doing something else
and I'm gonna claim what that's
something else he's doing right now is
it's really kind of fascinating so
there is the person who would
theoretically replace him were he to
step down his lieutenant governor his
he's got his name is Justin Fairfax
there's an article from website called
big-league politics big league politics
is also the site that originally
published the yearbook page of Ralph
Northam we are now learning that the
yearbook page of Ralph Northam was
probably released by somebody who was
angry at him for his stance on abortion
motives don't really matter in terms of
who releases it it's just how people
react to the page so big-league politics
released a an article about an
allegation regarding lieutenant governor
Justin Fairfax and the allegation was an
allegation that was put up on I believe
Facebook by a woman who suggested that
years ago in 2004 there was an aide at
the DNC who sexually assaulted her and
then she said that this person and and
she said that this person then went on
to become a statewide candidate for
office and eventually would be taking a
big step up in politics the actual
statement posted by a woman named Adria
and by Vanessa Tyson is the name of the
woman she wrote imagine you were
sexually assaulted during the DNC
convention in Boston in 2004 by a
campaign staffer you spend the next 13
years trying to forget it ever happened
until one day you find out he's the
Democratic candidate for statewide
office in a state some 3,000 miles away
and he wins that election in November
2017 then by strange horrible luck it
seems increasingly likely he'll get a
very big promotion so this allegation
has been out for several months and
big-league politics published the
allegation now lieutenant governor
Justin Fairfax has released a statement
about it the statement says tonight an
online publication released a false and
unsubstantiated allegation against
lieutenant governor Justin Fairfax
lieutenant governor Fairfax has an
outstanding and well-earned reputation
for treating people with dignity and
respect
he has never assaulted anyone ever in
any way shape or form the person
reported to be making this false
allegation first approached the
Washington Post one of the nation's most
prominent newspapers more than a year
ago around the time of the lieutenant
governor's historic inauguration the
post carefully investigated the claim
for several months after being presented
with facts consistent with the
lieutenant governor's denial of the
allegation the absence of any evidence
corroborating the allegation and
significant red flags in
within the allegation that post made the
considered decision not to publish the
story okay so this has led to
accusations that the Washington Post
spiked the story on behalf of Lieutenant
Governor Justin Fairfax now they're all
talking in one second about whether in
fact that allegation is justified
suffice it to say they're grave
suspicions today that governor of
Fairfax lieutenant governor of Fairfax
is being victimized by the leaks from
northerns office that basically nor them
in an attempt to save himself it's
saying well don't look at my black
lieutenant governor and say that that
guy is ready to be governor because um
there's this still hanging out there so
if that's the case if it is true that
Ralph northerns office is going after
his lieutenant governor that's playing
some real some real heavy-handed
hardball right there I mean that's not
some pretty low stuff as to the
allegation that the Washington Post
spiked this one thing that both the
northern story and the Fairfax story are
revealing is the insane double standard
that exists with regard to allegations
insane double standard
so the Washington Post apparently had
this information they had the allegation
and they never published it why because
it was uncorroborated there was no
supporting evidence and there were
significant red flags and
inconsistencies within the allegation
according to lieutenant governor Fairfax
his office all of which seems like a
pretty good reason not to publish a
story except that I'm old enough to
remember when the Washington Post and
every other major media outlet in the
country ran with allegations by
Christine Blasi Ford that had
significant red flags and
inconsistencies that had no
corroborating evidence and that were
blatantly denied by Brett Kavanaugh and
it became the subject of a full-scale
judicial hearing with Democrats
slandering the man as a possible gang
rapist
I remember when they ran with all of
these allegations and Michael a vinod he
was coming forward and suggesting that
he had evidence that Brett Kavanaugh
might in fact have participated in gang
rape and Kamala Harris the new
Democratic presidential candidate was
sitting up there implying the exact same
thing people ran with it so it is worth
noting that the same people in the media
who say oh yeah well we will never have
run with an allegation like that it was
just not substantiated enough those same
people were not willing to run with an
allegation we're willing to run with an
allegation against Brett Kavanaugh that
was very close to similar so that's
that's pretty that is pretty telling
about the media by the way the media
you have to make a side note here I
don't know if you watch the Super Bowl
yesterday if you did I'm sorry for the
hours that you wasted watching the Super
Bowl the Washington Post ran an ad in
the middle of the Super Bowl the same
Washington Post that did not run the
allegations against lieutenant governor
Fairfax which again I'm okay with if you
actually had that standard consistently
they spent something like 5.25 million
dollars to run an ad in the middle of
the Superbowl talking about democracy
dies in darkness
how many reporter salaries could that
have paid I I do love that I do love
that the Washington Post they're like
you know what we could do to really
restore reputation as a journalistic
entity what we could do is hire an actor
to talk about how awesome we are and
well glam off of Tom Hanks's curating in
order to pretend that people actually
like our journalism here is here's a
little bit of that Washington Post
self-serving ad yesterday during the
Superbowl
when we exercise our rights
[Music]
when we soar to our greatest Heights
when we mourn and pray
when our neighbors bar at risk
when our nation is threatened
there's someone to gather the facts
[Music]
to bring you the story
no matter the cost
[Music]
because knowing empowers us
knowing helps us decide
knowing keeps us free
was it I've been in favor of journalism
and says Washington Post democracy dies
in darkness I'm all in favor of
journalism at the back-patting
self-congratulatory nature of the
Washington Post patting itself on the
back for for journalism well at the same
time having such blatant doubled
standards and so much of their reporting
is pretty galling to a lot of Americans
and honestly it ought to be going to a
lot of Americans there's some other
problems with that Adam and explain what
those problems are with that add in just
one second then we'll get to the wide
and very democratic reaction to the
northern allegations and the yearbook
page and the whole deal first let's talk
about how you can make your back feel
better so as a person who works out a
lot I know I'm ripped man I mean you
should no one's ever gonna see it but
I'm just telling you you're gonna have
to take my word for it but that that
means that after I work out very often
my back aches okay I need to I need to
work on my form I know but like a lot of
people when I have a back ache that
means I need to do something about it
and that's why I have Teeter Teeter the
ax teeter inversion table is just
spectacular it sounds weird but hanging
upside down is a great way to decompress
the back and joints after a workout and
boost
recovery as well as called inversion
therapy it uses gravity and your own
bodyweight to decompress the spine and
release tension in your shoulders neck
and joint I mean did you even see the
Dark Knight Rises
that's exactly what Bruce Wayne does in
order to heal his back and you should do
it too this here inversion taper really
is pretty awesome over three million
people have put their trust in cedar
they've been the best known name an
inversion table since 1981 they're
offering a great deal just for my
listeners by the way Batman should have
used the teeter inversion table he
wouldn't had to spend time like down in
that hole like being hung by a rope to
fix his back or anything he just
would've been better rank for a limited
time you get the brand new 2019 Teeter
fits by an inversion table model but
bonus accessories and a free pair of
gravity boots so you can invert at home
or take the boots with you to the gym
teeter inversion tables have thousands
of reviews on Amazon with an average 4.6
star rating and with this deal you get
150 bucks off when you go to teeter calm
slash Ben that is teeter calm / Ben it's
free shipping free returns a 60 day
money back guarantee so you have nothing
to lose here go check it out right now
if you got back pain or you got neck
pain go check out Teeter comm / Ben and
get that new 2019 a teeter fit spine
inversion table with this special deal
that's te e ter comm / Ben 150 bucks off
when you go to teeter calm / Ben and
again free shipping for your turn 60 day
money back guarantee so give it a try
nothing to lose you'll feel better
Teeter calm / man I know it's made me
feel better so go check that out right
now okay so this Washington Post ad a
couple of quick notes on the Washington
Post ad that ran during the Superbowl
notice that when they say when the
nation is in grave danger and then they
show a picture of Oklahoma City now I'm
old enough to remember another event
they put our nation in grave danger and
led to us getting involved in two wars
that have been 9/11 but I guess we're
not allowed to show pictures of 9/11 on
TV lest it be offensive also they say
journalists who have died for their
profession and then they showed Jamal
khashoggi Jamal khashoggi
was an opinion writer for the for many
outlets including the Washington Post he
also happened to be closely aligned with
the ideology of the Muslim Brotherhood
so while the Saudi government should
obviously not have murdered Jamal
khashoggi I'm not gonna put him in the
same category
as I put other journalists or murdered
for their journalism also I gotta say
like the idea the journalists in the
United States are wildly in danger all
the time that the Washington Post is
sort of promoting here is obviously not
true all of the people who are killed in
that particular ad are people who were
killed abroad in foreign countries also
I would note that the Washington Post
which sort of suggests that American
journalism is constantly in danger like
thousands of journalists have been
arrested in Turkey and journalists are
routinely killed in Russia in China and
the sort of stuff is pretty common let's
stand with those people I'm not sure the
Washington Post necessarily measures up
except for their foreign correspondents
who obviously do okay so the Democratic
reaction to the Ralph Northam thing has
been kind of interesting basically
everybody who's in sort of day-to-day
democratic politics says let northern go
and everybody who's running for
president says northern should resign
that's the way this breaks down so Terry
McAuliffe
who is a former Virginia governor and
deeply involved in Democratic Party
politics he says he has no indication
that northern has been a racist and he
says maybe we should probably let this
guy go I know that the Ralph Northam you
know in your words is a good man but yet
has he also been a racist
I have zero indication of that as I say
family doctor and military service had
been a state senator ran for lieutenant
governor ralph was always at my side so
I can't answer it Jake I'm telling you
I'm heartbroken okay so I mean the
answer is has he ever been
as well I mean it depends do you think
that that photo means that he is
absolutely a racist and then you see
Howard Dean Howard Dean who's also not
running for president former head of the
DNC he says Republicans have no morals
at all so he tries to turn it on
Republicans that a Democratic governor
was just caught with his hand in the
black face jar Republicans you know they
have no morals at all
I mean you know the Republicans are
happy to ask Ralph Northam design they
have a much worse guy who's heading
heading their party it's ridiculous okay
so he's saying of course because Trump
is worse than northern that means that
Trump should resign almond or them
shouldn't resign I'm confused Democrats
think Trump should resign but northern
shouldn't resign they're gonna have to
explain that one now the Democrats who
are running for president have
universally called for him to step down
so Hillary Clinton who may or may not
run for president she says that northern
should go he got common with Harris who
says that northern should go yeah Cory
Booker who says that northern should go
you've got Julian Castro who Leon Castro
who is running for president but no one
cares and he says that northern should
resign as well I'm happy that at least
he has apologized and that he recognizes
that what he did was wrong and I do
think of course that there's the
opportunity to understand and accept his
apology
but I also believe that that's separate
and apart from him continuing in a
position of trust and authority which is
the governor's office so I hope that he
does resign well you know then this kind
of breakdown does demonstrate the what
the Democratic Party leadership thinks
of their own base so a lot of Democrats
on a day to day level are going listen
if our new standard is that anything bad
you did in the past means that you're
out of office there will be no one left
standing and then there are the people
who are running for office who are
saying well I have to somehow go back to
the base and I have to explain to them
why Ralph Northam should stay and I'm
just not going to do that it's it's kind
of fascinating to see the divide because
here is the truth the Democratic Party
honchos are correct if our standard if
our standard is that stuff that you did
35 years ago that was construed as
racist now but was construed as maybe
just irreverent or controversial then is
now the subject of you losing your
career there are gonna be a lot of
people out of jobs very very quickly
Robert a George is a member of the New
York editor of the New York Daily News
editorial board black eye and the reason
I mentioned is race is
the thread that we're about to read I
think it's worthwhile going through this
thread that he put up on Twitter because
I think this is the most nuanced take on
the Ralph Northam issue that I've heard
I think it's also the most accurate take
on the Ralph Northam issued that I've
heard here's what he says he says after
much fun at northerns expense a serious
thought a few tweets have run along the
lines of even in the south 35 years ago
everyone knew that wearing a Klan outfit
or blackface was racist having been in
college myself at the time I started
nodding but then I pause everyone knew
that this type of behavior is racist
that means nor them must have been
racist he admits in his Friday statement
that what he did was racist it means his
partner in crime was racist but there
was a compiler slash editor of the
yearbook right that was supposed that
supposedly reasonable person accepted
northerns photo and let it go right was
there a faculty advisor did that person
to prove it to my point here is that
either everyone knew this was something
really ugly and racist or they were
doing something that they bizarrely
thought was funny and no one stopped to
think oh it's funny but really ugly and
maybe we shouldn't do it
he says the 20/20 hindsight we have now
that everyone knew that something you
didn't do might not have been as strong
was was might not have been as strong
back then in other words if you think
now that everything bad like now it's
very easy to look at that photo and go
obvious racism gross get out of office
but is that how people thought of it
back then time context it does matter he
says to make it to make it a bit clearer
a personal anecdote I went to a small
liberal arts college in Maryland below
the mason-dixon line of the student body
of 400 I was one of five or six blacks
over four plus years in 1985 senior
class leaders bounced around ideas for a
fundraiser they settled upon a slave
auction seniors would be auctioned to
odd jobs for the winning bidders yeah
yeah already you're thinking what the
hell in fairness this was the school
which studies Greek and Latin classics
so it's theoretically possible to do a
Greek or Roman style slave auction even
so I approached the planners and said
tread carefully I didn't hear about it
anymore so I assumed it got dropped
instead I woke to find posters declaring
welcome to 1865 it's a real live slave
auction um what I well got upset but
here's the thing there were quite a few
other white friends including other
seniors who were stunned there was an
african-american underclassmen who I'd
become friends with who came up to me
and whatever the 1985 version of what
the bleep was I put together a strongly
worded letter no seriously was an open
letter to the student body
got it co-signed with a double a couple
dozen other people infuriated stuffed
copies and mail boxes a day or so late
the fundraiser was canceled yes there
are bruised feelings my african-american
pal and I had a tense discussion with
the organizers we clear the air and it
should be noted I'm friendly with them
to this day I don't consider them racist
then or now it was an insensitive action
but an ultimately learning moment in the
days that followed I felt out of sorts
even though I had many friends who had
my back and immediately supported me and
whatever I wanted to do in response I
was still feeling alone wondering if I
did the right thing
then something happened the auditorium
attendant african-american like the
entire grounds crew Jimmy came up to me
I chatted with him over the years I had
a work-study job in the dining hall he
said to me thank you for speaking up
about that these kids they just don't
know it had quite the impact these kids
just don't know
in truth I was a kid myself I didn't
know irritated as I was with the class
leaders who ignored my cautionary
heads-up in fact this was bigger than me
bigger than them other eyes were
watching so beware the everyone knew
such-and-such was racist in 1985 Trump
Ralph Northam is a few years older than
I am he should have known better but so
should several other people involved in
getting that photo into the yearbook hey
kids it wasn't the selfie the definition
of racism isn't as set in stone as we
might like the spectrum of racially
insensitive or microaggressions who out
and to out-and-out racism is to use an
invoke phrase fluid some get it right
away others they just don't know okay
this is of course exactly right this is
exactly right in a second I'm gonna
explain why it's exactly right and why a
little bit of grace might go a long way
in our politics or we can keep
destroying each other because it's
convenient to do so first let's talk
about your sleep quality okay so if
you're not sleeping all that well you
might think that it's because the
temperature in your room or maybe it's
because of the mattress upon which you
are sleeping because your body is built
like no other body and yet you're
sleeping on a mattress that was built
just generically for random humans
instead you should go check out helix
sleep helix sleep has built a sleep quiz
it takes two minutes to complete they
use the answers to match your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress whether you're a side sleeper a
hot sleeper whether you like a plush or
a firm bed with helix there's no more
guessing and no more confusion just go
to helix sleep calm slash bend take
their two minutes sleep quiz they will
match you to a mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life for
couples helix can even split the
mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and fuel
preferences for each side they have a 10
year warranty you get to try it out for
100 nights risk-free right now helix is
offering up to 125 bucks off all
mattress orders get up to 125 bucks off
at helix sleep calm slash Ben that's
Hewett sleep calm slash been for 125
dollars off your mattress order again
helix sleep calm slash man my wife and I
love our helix sleep mattress we took
that two-minute sleep because the
mattress came in the mail we unwrapped
it it inflated right in front of us we
popped it on the bed good to go it's so
comfortable we got one for my sister for
her wedding go check it out right now
helix sleep comm slash button for 125
bucks off your mattress order okay I
have a few more thoughts on the Ralph
Northam controversy and then I want to
get to the latest on Jesse Smollett and
my situation over at Grand Canyon
University which is getting all weird
but for all that you're gonna have to go
subscribe over at daily wire to get the
rest of this show live daily we're calm
to get two additional hours of me every
day we are slaving away for you people
we are in that hot kitchen slaving over
the stove working our fingers to the
bone and all other form of metaphor for
how hard we're working go check it out
for $9.99 a month you can be part of our
team you can help us out we always
appreciate that also we have a daily
wire state-of-the-union backstage that
is coming up on tomorrow night so if the
same units tomorrow night that's when
we're doing it so we will be there
guiding you through the process you can
ask questions in our mailbag you can ask
questions to me you can ask questions to
all the other folks over at the daily
wire like all sorts of goodies plus one
for $99 here you get all that stuff and
this the leftist here's hot or cold
tumblr check this out Wow unreal
incredible unbelievable stupendous
tremendous unbelievable go check it out
right now also go subscribe over at
youtuber iTunes got a great Sunday
special this week with Dave Ramsey you
didn't have access to it on Saturday you
could have had access if you'd subscribe
more fool you that would've been a good
financial investment don't you think I
think you should have gone and checked
out or you can go subscribe over at
youtube or itunes when you do leave us a
review we always appreciate where the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so we have completely obliterated and
this is the point I think Robert a
George is making we have completely
obliterated any distinction between
racially insensitive or racial jokes or
stuff that's sort of uncomfortable and
out-and-out racism and we have
obliterated that distinction going retro
actively so if you watch blazing set
people make this joke all the time but
it's true if you'll watch Blazing
Saddles now there is no way in hell that
movie ever gets made right there are KKK
jokes there are jokes about black folks
there are jokes about Jews there are
jokes about everything in that movie
you're not allowed to tell any of those
jokes now Mel Brooks would never have a
career now you simply cannot tell an
offensive joke and I'm not sure that the
country is significantly better for that
honestly like as a Jew there are a lot
of Jewish jokes out there a lot of nasty
vicious Jewish jokes but it does I will
say that I think a sense of humor
inability to to kind of look aside when
people are acting like jackasses is
better for your soul and better for the
country then the sort of search for
microaggressions that we have today now
there is a happy medium which is people
could not be jerks and also we could be
a little bit less we could also be a
little bit less sensitive about things I
think that's actually where we should be
meaning that not all of those bad jokes
ought to be told right we should be like
I'm not a fan of racial jokes for
example I don't think that people should
tell racial jokes I also think that
people do tell racial jokes we are
better served as a society not by trying
to destroy their lives but by people
kind of going okay guys being a jerk
guys been in a bleep Riley I think that
the this newfound crusade that we have
to destroy people based on stuff they
did 30 years ago particularly is really
bad now I think that there's a case we
made that if somebody does something now
that's really bad that that there should
be immediate repercussions for that but
the world that we are building in which
we dig up somebody's old high school or
medical school yearbook and then free of
context we say well everyone knew it was
bad then as Robert a George says I am
Not sure that is the case I'm not sure
that is the case I think that is
certainly possible that some people knew
that it was bad then or it's possible
people were ignorant they weren't
surrounded by people who knew better
they didn't have good conversations with
folks who were more aware of the
problematic nature of some of this stuff
and so instead of attributing this to
racial malice like Ralph Northam was a
Knight Rider or something maybe he's
just an idiot
maybe he's a racially insensitive idiot
and maybe if he'd been confronted about
it he would have apologized at the time
how many times have you done something
offensive in your life and been
confronted about it and then you
apologize because you realize you just
offended somebody
I'm sure that's happened to you many
times how would you like it if nobody
said anything for 20 years and then they
brought it up and said now we're gonna
take away your career from you I think
that that's gonna make for a really ugly
America already is making for a really
ugly America I was discussing this with
some friends over the weekend again none
of this is to excuse Ralph Northam
dressing in blackface or in a KKK outfit
or any of this I think all of that stuff
is really egregious but we're not
discussing the egregious nature of that
except in so far as to say that on the
spectrum of egregious behavior that
should finish your career decades into
the future this one lies on the margin
okay really if you're talking about
things that should finish our career I
would say actual membership in the KKK
like Robert Byrd that probably should
finish your career and not make you the
conscience of the Senate for 50 years I
think if you kill a woman by driving off
a bridge with it with her in the
backseat did that probably should finish
your career not lead to a presidential
run in 1980 and a lion ization as the
Lion of the Senate like that stuff
probably is bad enough that it should
finish her career
dressing up in a racist fashion in a
yearbook in 1985 I'm not sure that that
should finish your career 34 years in
the future I'm just not sure that that's
that that lies there like there are
gradations here
as to what should finish your career but
here's the thing there are three ways
that we deal with bad stuff that we've
done in our past and as a culture we
become very confessional culture so
there are three ways to deal with bad
stuff that we've done in our past way
number one is that we beat everybody to
the punch this is the Barack Obama
strategy for dealing with bad stuff
you've done so if you're Barack Obama
and you're running for president or
think of running for political office
and you know that back in your high
school days you did cocaine and maybe
handed out some to your friends what you
do is you write in your autobiography I
did a little blow I may have done a
little cocaine and then everyone goes oh
well you know he admitted it he admitted
it he said it was bad what do you want
from it and then it's off the table so
that's way number one is the
confessional culture you preemptively
declare all of your sins now this
specifically works well for people who
are in the political business so if you
are Ralph Northam and you knew you were
going straight from medical school into
politics you've done
like immediately upon exiting medical
school you decide oh my god that
yearbook was terrible i bare my soul
terrible for the nation so that's option
number one is the pre-emptive the
pre-emptive confession and that's what
we prefer in our confessional culture in
a second I'm gonna give you the other
two options okay option number two when
it comes to bad behavior option number
two is that you just try to forget about
it you try to forget about it and then
when somebody raises it then you
apologize for it so how many things have
you done in your life that you think are
really bad like really bad that you're
embarrassed of I would wager that
literally every person who is listening
to this show right now
journalist left right sensor it doesn't
matter all of you have done something in
your life that you're embarrassed of and
you would not want to be public because
it is embarrassing and so you have a
choice are you going to like post a
diary entry about it online today or are
you just gonna say does anybody even
remember me doing that like I hope
nobody remembers me doing that because
it was really embarrassing like I
remember it I'm embarrassed by it
bringing it up now creates new issues
with my business with my family so I
really need to do that like I'm sorry
for it my entire life has been a
repudiation of that so I really need to
go back and relive that and rip that
scab open now that I've worked hard to
move on with my life now again it
depends on the nature of the sin as to
whether this is morally okay or not like
you kill a person probably you should
confess that but you dressed up in a
yearbook for medical school 34 years ago
and then you spent 30 years caring for
minority children in your Pediatrics
clinic and now you you're working on
minority kids daily what do you have to
do post a giant poster like in the
waiting room of your clinic of you and
say I'm sorry for this probably you do
what most people do and you do this on a
daily basis with your friends and family
now you do it with your wife or your
husband with your spouse with your
girlfriend you do this all the time
right you spit you do something to the
spouse and you think man that was really
bad maybe I should have done that well
maybe she didn't notice right as a human
being it's a tendency and then if she
raised it like you know what I shouldn't
have done that that was stupid I'm sorry
okay so that's possibility number two so
possibility number one is the
confessional possibility number two is
you try to forget it and move beyond it
and then if somebody raises it then you
apologize for it and then there's
possibility number three which is
somebody raises the issue and then you
double down on it right you because
here's the problem with option number
two if you take option number two
somebody brings it up thirty four years
ago you dressed in racist fashion in a
yearbook 34 years ago and you say you
know what you're right I'm sorry I
shouldn't done that the follow-up
question from badly motivated people
always is so why didn't you apologize
before why didn't you take option number
one why didn't you go out there and do a
Dashboard Confessional
why didn't you go out there and write a
full on Facebook post about it so we
could have cast you out before any of
this started we could have ruined your
life preemptively because here's the
dirty little secret for a lot of folks
if they had done this sort of
confessional culture thing if Ralph
Northam had done this before the
primaries that would have finished his
career so he felt okay you know what I'm
not gonna talk about it because it's not
an important character Iser of Who I am
as a person so I'm not gonna talk about
it and then it gets raised and now he
has two options one is he tried it both
ways you could actually see him try
option one and option three here he
tried it number one where he you can see
sorry he tried option two and option
three he said okay you brought it up I'm
gonna apologize for it and then people
jumped on him and said why didn't you do
this before what's wrong with you where
were you for 30 years on this and his
answer was well for 30 years I've been
trying to live down the shame of having
done that and trying to move beyond that
but that's not enough for people so then
it turns into okay I'm gonna double down
what this leads to is a politics where
your best characteristic as a politician
is having no shame at all that you don't
care about the bad stuff you did in the
past and if somebody brings it up to you
then usually instead of apologizing you
just say yeah f you I don't care
whatever whatever man you wanna make a
big deal about it float your boat right
that's why Donald Trump is very
successful in politics because he takes
option three all the time option three
is always double down which means he
never get to ask the follow-up question
- option number two he never get to ask
the follow-up question well why didn't
you do this earlier why didn't you
apologize earlier because he never
apologizes people bring stuff up to him
and he just says whatever I don't care
so what you're gonna get is more
politicians like that here you get more
politicians who don't have a sense of
shame who don't have a sense of guilt
who say you know what screw this entire
system because you're being dishonest
and here's the truth I think a lot of
people in politics on every side are
being wildly dishonest when they bring
up old material to club people to death
with I've been pretty consistent about
this whether we are talking about film
directors
where people go and dig through their
old tweets or Kevin Hart or people are
digging up through his old tweets trying
to destroy him this is an ugly Society
we've created for ourselves in social
media you honestly there are just people
who are lucky that cell phones did not
exist 40 years ago because now
everything that you do is captured on
camera so everybody is very wary of what
they do on camera but the only thing
with Ralph Anora honestly the only thing
that happened to Ralph Northam is that
there was a camera present when he did
this you know many politicians probably
dressed in blackface over the last 35
years dressed up as Michael Jackson or
OJ Simpson or something for a Halloween
party if there were cameras present and
all of those places do you know many
politicians there would be from the baby
boomer generation zero legitimately zero
so here's your choice Americans here's
our choice our choices we can either see
these things in the context of a less
sensitive time which has good aspects
and bad aspects less sensitive means
that people are less offended all the
time it also means that people do more
insensitive things which is bad right
what I would like is for people to be
more sensitive but also more sensitive
to others and less sensitive toward
their own feelings like that that would
be the ideal is that your soul in the
Jewish prayers we say that every morning
your soul is like dust to your enemies
but by the same token you try to be kind
to people and non offensive to to other
people with all of that said we live in
a political culture where you are
supposed to cast your opponents in the
worst possible light at all times and if
that means going back into the past
digging up stuff and then forcing them
into a corner and beating them then you
do it then you do it so there's no grace
there's no forgiveness
there's no seeing people in the best
possible light there's no attempt to see
people as the totality of a group of
characteristics instead it's you did
this one bad thing back way back a long
time ago when honestly people were more
ignorant and people weren't as sensitive
and now we're gonna destroy you for it I
don't know that we can have a politics
that operates along these lines I'm not
sure who survives these politics other
than people who we have deemed immune
for intersectional reasons and there are
people who have deemed immune for
intersectional reasons that if you
apologize for your own privilege or if
you happen to be a member of an
intersectional group that has been
historically victimized you can say
whatever you want so you can be an
anti-semite if you are ranking if you
you are a black candidate for office who
hangs out who is Farrakhan and if you're
if you are Rashid it's live and you're
Muslim then you can be anti-semitic as
you want to be but it doesn't matter
because you're intersectional it's all
of this is incoherent it's divisive it's
ugly
it means the worst politics for the
country as a general rule and none of
this is defense of Ralph Northam zere
book page what it is is is a call for us
to look like I think into our own hearts
and decide what kind of politics we
would like to have on an ongoing basis
of politics that involves at least a
little bit of forgiveness or a politics
of pure unadulterated justice with 20/20
hindsight where everybody has had to be
perfect forever and if not then we will
go ahead and rip them down off their
pedestal and and beat them to death all
righty let's get to some things I like
and then we'll do some things that I
hate so things that I like over the
weekend I've been reading a lot of
sports because I just need distraction
from politics these days I'm just
annoyed by the political scene I'll be
honest with you and so I've been reading
a lot of sports books if you're into
sports books this is one of the great
sports books of the recent past
Jack McCallum longtime columnist for
Sports Illustrated he wrote a book right
after the 1992 Olympics called dream
team all about the USA basketball team
which was you know the greatest
conglomeration of basketball talents
ever put on one court it was Bird and
Magic and Jordan and Charles Barkley and
Patrick Ewing and David Robinson and an
amazing bevy of talent and the book
itself is a lot of fun it's it's gossipy
and it's it's about honestly like an
aspirational it gives you an
aspirational feeling about the country
and about our ability to get along with
each other despite our differences so
it's well worth reading go check it out
dream team by Jack McCallum that one is
a lot of fun I think that you will enjoy
it okay other things that I like so
Andrew Sullivan has a has a fascinating
piece today it's hilarious called the
nature of sex and Andrew Sullivan is a
gay man and his basic contention is that
if you try to separate out sex from
gender in essence you're going to be
reading out the gay and lesbian movement
because if you say the sex and gender
are entirely disconnected and that a
biological man can actually be a woman
then a lesbian should be able to be with
a biological man who is in fact a woman
and a lot of lesbians remember will hold
up a second like that's not something
I'm interested in
if this is a biological dude with all
the biological appendages and he calls
himself a woman I'm not attracted to
that and you can't call me a transphobic
because of that and yet that's exactly
what's happening right the new move in
kind of radical transyl's is to say that
Caitlyn Jenner not only is a woman but
always was a woman and therefore if you
were a lesbian you should have been
attracted to Caitlyn Jenner back when
Caitlyn Jenner was fully attached to all
of his original parts
Sandra Sullivan has a long piece about
this today talking about how the
destruction of biological sex actually
destroys lesbian and gay rights
he says the court disagreement it seems
to me is whether a trans woman is right
to say that she has always been a woman
it was born female and is
indistinguishable from and
interchangeable with biological women he
says most of us find this argument hard
to swallow entirely we may accept that
Caitlyn Jenner who came out as a woman
in 2015 I always understood herself as a
woman and see the psychological
conviction as sincere and to be
respected but we also see a difference
between someone who lived her life is a
man for decades under the foley under
the full influence of male chromosomes
and testosterone and whose society
socially accepted as male and then
transitioned and a woman to whom none of
these apply okay but he's being ripped
up and down for all of this and it's
hilarious it's why the the attempt to
it's why the attempt to link together
LGBTQ doesn't make any sense right LGB
are all sexual orientations T is a
sexual identity that's not the same
thing and these aspects of the LGBT
movement are finding themselves in
conflict now it's hilarious about all of
this is that of course it's it's just as
true of straight people I like that it
took a gay man to point out that by the
way I may not be attracted to biological
women well why is it that straight
people been saying right there's
differences between men and women never
as like are those straight people with
their with their sexism and then gay
people say like oh okay I guess that's
true so that's kind of hilarious
so you can go read the piece by Andrew
Sullivan it is somewhat telling about
the state of our politics in the nation
at this point okay time for some things
that I hate
so many things to hate today so first of
all I will point out that the Super Bowl
stunk it was terrible
the only redeeming quality of the Super
Bowl is the Tom Brady one yes I rooted
for greatness sorry sue me hey The Daily
Beast though had a full piece before the
before the Super Bowl and it was titled
I kid you not Tom Brady's New England
Patriots are the Team Magma our team
maggle whether they like it or not they
said their star quarterback coach and
owner all supported Trump but that's not
the only thing that makes the Super Bowl
bound Patriots the preferred team of
white nationalists hey you're doing it
wrong Corbin Smith of The Daily Beast
learn to code my goodness is it so this
is the new thing is that the Patriots
are the team of white nationalists all
right you know if that's the direction
you're gonna go the worst tweet I saw
yesterday was from the crass and
esteemed brothers who are just hilarious
examples of strange humans and one of
them tweeted out while other people are
shouting let's go Patriots or let's go
Rams I'm shouting let's go robert muller
and it's like okay are you like watching
this alone from your padded cell the
Superbowl well you're just in a
straitjacket screaming at the walls
let's go mall or well Tom Brady drives
down the field throwing passes to Julian
Edelman if you've let politics take over
your life to this extent I would suggest
that you may be nuts okay other things
that I hate today so the media I love
the media in the sense that they're
terrible so Jesse Jesse Smollett you'll
remember this story from last week the
suggestion was that he'd been walking
down the mean streets of Chicago at 2:00
a.m. coming back from a subway and he
was carrying a sub sandwich and two guys
who were two guys two white guys came
out of the woodwork one threw a rope
around his neck and then they started
shouting this is mega country while they
beat him up well now it turns out that a
couple of problems okay a couple of
problems according to Rafer Weigel of
Fox 32 in Chicago the he apparently was
missing from the tape for a minute when
he re-entered the tape he had a news
strung around his neck but he didn't
call the police for 40 minutes also when
he came back into the tape he was still
carrying his subway sandwich which is
weird like normally when you're
assaulted and someone pours
leech on you and puts a noose around
your neck and shouts this in Agra
country and breaks your rib which was
his original contention when that
happens I mean you really must love
Subway sandwiches right like you must be
super into that sandwich like you're
getting your ass kicked by a bunch of it
by a couple of racists on Chicago Street
in 20-degree below weather at 2:00 a.m.
and a break in your rib and you still
hang on to that subway sandwich man you
are either hungry or you love Subway
sandwiches for some perverse reason
really weird stuff so anyway
jussie Smollett did some sort of concert
and there he talked about his courage
and the headline from all of the media
outlets where how courageous trusty
smell it was nobody has yet asked him
straight questions about like all the
inconsistencies in his story but at
least we know he's very brave because he
performed in a concert and talked about
how he'd been mischaracterized okay well
again like some details would be good I
like that he has to read the statement
off a card he can't just say it which is
always the sign that you're not trying
to be legally careful is that your is
that your reading off an actual printed
note card at a concert in any case we
still don't know all the details maybe
it happened just the way he said it did
but I don't think that it's irrelevant
to ask questions about how this thing
went down considering again there been a
lot of inconsistencies in his story and
who wouldn't turn his cell phone over to
the police so a few things okay other
things that I hate today so Grand Canyon
University canceled a speaking
engagement that it's been scheduled for
me in a couple of months and they
canceled it because I'm apparently a
very scary human and they put out an
incredibly long statement about why they
canceled my speech there here's what
they said we wanted to take a moment to
address Grand Canyon University's
decision to cancel a speaking engagement
on campus by Ben Shapiro we believe in
many of the things that ben shapiro
speaks about and stands for including
his support for ideals that grow out of
traditional judeo-christian values and a
belief in a free-market economy our
decision to counsel Shapiro speaking
engagement is not a reflection of his
ideologies or the values
represents but rather a desire to focus
on opportunities that bring people
together to understand that decision one
has to first understand the university's
history and culture that has been
created on our campus as a private
interdenominational Christian
institution Grand Canyon University's
core beliefs are rooted in biblical
truths and outlined in our doctrinal
statement an ethical position statement
these foundational documents inspired in
large part by the Nicene Creed
articulate our commitment to the full
inspiration of Scripture and provide
clarity unity and alignment across the
university on matters of ethics and
morality then they talk about their very
diverse student body and their their
ability to offer education to all
socioeconomic classes when they talk
about their culture and how kind they
are they say in short it has created a
unique and united community no matter
where no matter their political
differences people come together as one
to make a difference in the world around
them today we live in a very divided
America the current high volume of
rhetoric has not led to community
building or problem solving Grand Canyon
University rather than engage in this
type of rhetoric has instead work to
bring people together and build
partnerships to renovate our inner city
community and then they talk about all
of the wonderful things they've done for
the inner city community as a university
we encourage thoughtful discussions and
rational dialogue in our classrooms
about the issues affecting our societies
and we encourage student to put the
students to put greater emphasis on
actions that produce positive change in
our society they say based on the
response we have received from some
within the Grand Canyon community
regarding the decision involving such
high-profile speakers as Ben Shapiro
we've obviously disappointed and
offended some of you we know that if we
had made a different decision we would
have disappointed and offended others
within the same community it was not our
intent to disappoint or offend anyone
it was rather to use our position as a
Christian University to bring unity to a
community that sits amidst a country
that is extremely divided and can't seem
to find a path forward toward unity yeah
well that's a pretty weak statement I'm
sorry to break it to you GCU but if you
are seeking unity probably the worst way
to go about that is to simply ban
debating voices to ban dissenting voices
hey my events are unfailingly polite go
watch my events they are incredibly
polite obviously what happened here is
that a couple of motivated professors at
GCU
decided that they were going to speak up
to the administration and the
administration cave to them or a couple
of students apparently according to
reporting people were upset about
position on daca which doesn't even make
any sense honest-to-goodness I mean
people who listen to the show no I'm
actually libertarian on immigration as
long as it is not raising the crime
rates as long as people are not coming
here to use welfare and as long as
they're not assimilation problems with
citizenship and yet apparently even a
whiff of controversy was enough for GCU
to run screaming for the hills
so well done there well done there
meanwhile I wonder if they would they
would reject somebody from the left who
was in any way controversial speaking of
which
final thing that I hate for today fresh
face of the Democratic Party so fresh so
face Alexandria Ocasio Cortez apparently
she had a wonderful conversation with
Jeremy Corbyn the ridiculous disgusting
anti-semitic piece of filth who runs the
Labour Party in Britain he said great to
speak to AOC on the phone this evening
and hear firsthand how she's challenging
the status quo let's build a movement
across borders to take on the
billionaire's polluters and migrant
Bader's and support a happier freer and
cleaner planet and then aoc tweeted it
was an honor to share such a lovely and
wide-reaching conversation with you
jeremy corbyn also honored to share a
great hope in the peace prosperity
injustice that everyday people can
create when we uplift one another across
class race and identity both at home and
abroad is it possible that the modern
Democratic Party has a serious problem
with allowing anti-semitism to flourish
inside its ranks I think that that's
pretty obvious at this point and we're
going to continue to pretend that
they're tolerant and open and diverse
when in fact many on the radical left
are precisely the opposite and a o'seas
association with one of the worst people
in the West Jeremy Corbyn is just the
latest indicator of that alrighty so
we'll be back here a little bit later
today with all the update to have a
couple of more hours of programming
coming up later with all the updates and
prep for the State of the Union recipe
there or we'll see you here tomorrow and
prep for the State of the Union I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Adam sy Yvette's audio
is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup
is by Joshua alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19